now to ukraine where russia is using its
devastating firepower to try to breach
ukrainian defenses russian bombs and
shells are hitting the city of harkiev
which is under ukraine's control
while fierce ground battles rage in the
eastern part of the country president
zielenski visited harkev over the
weekend imtiaz tayab has the latest on
the fighting in ukraine
well ukraine's prime minister says 10
times more civilians have been killed
than military personnel since the start
of the invasion and with russian forces
advancing in the eastern dawn bass the
beer is that number will only rise
street by street
village by village russian forces are
seizing more and more territory as they
try to conquer the eastern danvas region
ukrainian troops are outnumbered seven
to one here as moscow's siege tactics
overwhelm several areas
[Applause]
but there's no greater reminder of the
horrors this war has already inflicted
than in medieval
new video appears to show mass graves as
far as the eye can see
a pain unbearable for the few who remain
there
but in a show of strength and
determination vladimir zelinski was on
the ground in kharkiv ukraine's second
largest city recently wrestled back from
russia the president hasn't been seen
outside the kiev region since russia's
invasion began over three months ago and
was greeted with near total devastation
but as russia wages its war of attrition
ukraine has a secret weapon its people
these women are stitching together body
armor vests for the front line
sergei milton is
everyone here has loved ones in the
military he says and so we're careful to
make things as high quality as possible
so in a way this is a labor of love for
the people who make these materials
absolutely absolutely absolutely
how most ukrainians feel about vladimir
putin couldn't be clear this gravestone
stands outside another volunteer center
where we meet oleg zuboyak who takes us
around the facility and shows us
camouflage made for sniper using
household plastics as zaboyak
demonstrates
well you make a very convincing sniper
hello
but it's here some of the most useful
work is being done these women weave
together camouflage netting to be used
in the battlefield says volunteer
valentina really you're all just doing
anything you can to help absolutely
absolutely she says i've been working
here for three months without a single
day off because we need to do this now
despite suffering heavy losses in the
eastern dondas ukrainian forces are on
the counter-attack in the south of the
country claiming to have pushed back
russian forces out of three villages in
the kursan region for cbs mornings i'm
mps tithe in southeastern ukraine